bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
est ce qu'il ya des raisons de
s'inquiéter aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est
à l'aube de la fameuse deuxième vague de
couronnes un virus que l'on redoute
temps est-ce que vous constaté un afflux
de patients dans votre hôpital
bonjour écoutez oui on a on a un petit
afflux de patients dans notre hôpital
mais je pense que la situation en région
parisienne n'est pas aussi inquiétante
qu'elle peut l'être par exemple en
mayenne dont vous avez parlé ou alors
dans une moindre mesure en bretagne la
gironde ou dans les bouches du rhône que
vous n'avez pas cité et moi aussi
ils sont en train de faire face à un
début de rebond disons un début de
deuxième vague elle les patients malades
aujourd'hui et ce qu'elles ont des
symptômes plus ou moins violents que
lors de la première vague alors on sait
évidemment que cela dépend beaucoup d'un
profil à un autre mais la question
finalement c est ce qu on a une idée ce
que vous pouvez nous dire si on a une
idée concernant la mutation ou non du
virus
alors effectivement on a entendu parler
du fait que le virus avait muté alors il
faut savoir que ce genre de virus a une
grande capacité une éducation
néanmoins il est un peu trop tôt pour
dire si la symptomatologie différent de
ce qu'on a vu lors de la précédente lors
de la première vague en tout cas ce qui
est clair c'est pour beaucoup d'entre
nous les signes que l'on observe chez
les malades nous rappelle énormément les
signes que l'envoyer en février
justement avant que la grosse vague nous
submerge et en matière de tests de
masques ou encore de places en
réanimation est ce que la france serait
prête à faire face à une deuxième vague
selon écoutez c'est difficile de faire
des prévisions
on l'espère on espère que les leçons de
la première vague ont été tirés qu'on
sera capable de faire face en même temps
on ne peut pas résoudre déficit de lit
un déficit des hôpitaux un déficit de
personnel non médical de personnel
médical comme ça du jour au lendemain
en plus on est en pleine saison estivale
donc il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
sont parties en vacances et donc écouter
on espère que l'amplitude de la vague ne
sera pas très importante et qu'on aura
une qu'on arrivera là géré correctement
et ajustements pour y faire face on
évoque aujourd'hui des tests disponibles
en pharmacie de quoi s'agit t est ce
qu'il vous semble fiable alors les tests
qui sont disponibles en pharmacie sont
ceux que qui viennent d'apparaître sur
l'écran ce sont des tests qui permettent
de détecter des anticorps anti corps qui
sont de deux types ceux qui apparaissent
précocément et ceux qui apparaissent un
peu plus tardivement cette partie des
personnes qui pensent qu'un test
sérologique doit s'interpréter dans un
contexte clinique et que les médecins
sont quand même les mieux placés pour
faire la synthèse entre les résultats du
test et la présentation clinique
donc ça ma part et ça m'a paru
intéressant effectivement mais je pense
qu'il sera un accent important disputé
les résultats avec les médecins et
surtout donne pas forcément se fier un
test négatif à un test positif parce
qu'on ne connaît pas bien les
performances de ces tests encore
et parmi les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires après l'avoir longtemps jugés
non essentiels le masque va donc être
rendu obligatoire dans les lieux publics
clos dès la semaine prochaine si tout le
monde le porte
ce masque est ce qu'on est assurée de
diminuer drastiquement le nombre de
contaminations
oui oui absolument votre votre question
est tout à fait pertinente il faut le
redire aux personnes qui nous écoutent
le masque est quand même la meilleure
art que l'on est à notre disposition
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir prévenir cette
deuxième vague pour pouvoir éviter cette
deuxième vague
donc il faut vraiment porter le masque
dans tous les lieux clos et qu'il n'y
ait pas de dents torse à cette règle
après rend le masque obligatoire est une
chose mais il faut envisager le
remboursement du mas en tout cas sa mise
à disposition
pour la population générale parce que
tout le monde ne peut pas se payer à
masquer tous les jours de l'année
voilà merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage avec comme chef du service des
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière à paris